okay leute es ist mal wieder soweit am 6
november hat ihre maske etwas getraut
hat normalerweise machen natürlich nicht
jedes mal ein video nur weil irland
seine gedanken auf dem porzellan thron
mit uns teilt aber dieses mal war es
etwas anders seine community sollte
nämlich entscheiden ob eon einen
signifikanten teil seiner tesla aktien
verkaufen soll oder anders gesagt ein
tweet bzw eine abstimmung entscheidet
über 20 milliarden us dollar circa 18 8
milliarden euro das spannende ist eine
maßzahl so endlich mal wieder steuern
okay was ist da los warum entscheidet
ein tweet und nicht zb das gesetz oder
so ob der reichste mensch der erde
steuern zahlt und sollten wir vielleicht
eine extrasteuer für superreiche
einführen heute geht es um finanzen es
geht um große beträge und langweilige
gesetze hinter den milliardäre ihre
milliarden- versteckt dass es auf den
ersten blick eines der spannendsten
themen aber vielleicht eines der
wichtigsten und deswegen geht es heute
genau darum bei doktor watson
[Musik]
the
world we go in santana den terror
exportieren in politik
[Musik]
yuan max
distribution network
jeff bezos in omas und bill gates haben
alle wahnsinnig viel geld von was für
summen wieder reden kann man sich aber
eigentlich gar nicht mit einem
menschlichen gehirn vorstellen deswegen
haben wir mal ein bisschen rum gerechnet
das deutsche bruttoinlandsprodukt
hatte
nicht zu essen keine kleidung nicht
einmal steuern oder versicherungen keine
sündhaft teuren apple teenies nach
feierabend und auch keine unterstützung
für doktor watson auf patrick schade was
glaubt ihr mit wie viel geld ich am ende
da stehen richtig natürlich mit fast 93
millionen dollar herzlichen glückwunsch
an die geübten kopfrechner unter euch
aber noch viel wichtiger das sind gerade
mal
0,03 prozent von elon musk
286 milliarden dollar großen vermögen
aber gut die woche hat ja mehr als fünf
tage jemand wie elon musk macht bestimmt
nicht feierabend nur weil gerade
wochenende ist und wenn man so hart
arbeitet verdient man ja bestimmt auch
einiges mehr als der deutsche
durchschnitt sagen wir also ich arbeite
seit dem ja nur für sieben tage die
woche und bekomme jeden tag 10.000
dollar jeden tag steuerfrei bar auf die
kralle dann wird meine jahrtausende
lange harte arbeit mit immerhin sieben
milliarden dollar belohnt
aber auch das sind gerade mal gerundet
2,6 prozent von ihnen max vermögen also
was lernen wir daraus der reichste
mensch der welt ist verdammt reich aber
ganz wichtig das geld liegt nicht
einfach so auf seinem taschengeld konnte
um wenn wir von seinem reichtum reden
dem 286 milliarden dollar dann sprechen
wir vor allem von firmenanteilen primär
natürlich tesla wenn man sagt dass elon
musk immer reicher wird dann heißt das
eigentlich dass die firmenanteile von in
omas im wert steigen nicht die zahl auf
seinem konto diese milliarden von dollar
von dem wir immer reden die hatten nicht
er muss erst seine aktien verkaufen und
das ist ja genau das worüber seine
twitter follower gerade entscheiden
durften und auch erst dann kommt die
steuer ins spiel so weit so gut und
ehrlich gesagt ich war überrascht als
ich seinen tweet gesehen habe von außen
sieht das ja ein bisschen so aus als
würde er sich mit der idee anfreunden
einen teil seines vermögens mit steuern
zurückzugeben super aber wenn man sich
mal genau damit beschäftigt dann fällt
auf dass worüber seine community
entscheiden dürfte da stand eigentlich
schon monate frühjahr fest und wird
wahrscheinlich nicht aus bösem willen
sondern aus wirtschaftlichen gründen
gemacht dazu könnte übrigens mehr unter
der quelle nummer vier erfahren ok
steuern müssen eben manchmal gezahlt
werden und es ist ja auch gut dass
selbst der reichste mensch der welt zur
kasse gebeten wird was ihn am asphalt
manchmal überhaupt gar keine steuern da
genau zum beispiel 2018 jeder von euch
der 2018 gearbeitet hat hat in diesem
jahr mehr steuern gezahlt als in london
bevor wir weitermachen müssen wir aber
erst einmal unsere eigenen steuern
finanzieren denn das heutige video wird
unterstützt von blink ist und ihr werdet
auch sehen für dieses video hier haben
wir wirklich viele viele quellen gelesen
aber wo fängt man da eigentlich an wie
startet man in ein thema wo ist so
unfassbar viele verschiedene meinungen
und paper und standpunkte gibt genau
hier kommt links ins spiel der blick ist
nimmt ganze bücher und macht aus ihnen
15 minütige text und audio erklärer
sogenannte links und die gibt es ganz
viel über superreiche aber auch über die
wirtschaftlichen hintergründe und das
ist eine riesige debatte mit unzähligen
standpunkten und theorien blinkt jetzt
kann hier helfen sich einen überblick zu
verschaffen und mitzureden wenn ihr euch
für die steuertricks der reichsten der
reichen interessiert dann kann ich euch
zum beispiel treasure island von michael
jackson empfehlen und wenn ihr wirklich
ganz vorne anfangen wollte also ich ganz
ganz ganz vorne könnt ihr euch auf
linkes wealth of nations von adams mit
erklären lassen das ist ganz bescheiden
gesagt wahrscheinlich das
einflussreichste wirtschaftsbuch aller
zeiten insgesamt sind auch linke ist
über 4.500 sachbücher und podcasts aus
so ziemlich allem was die wissenschaft
zu bieten hat falls euch das alles
interessiert und auch tiefer in so
ziemlich jedes thema eintauchen wollt
dann gibt es jetzt eine extra aktion für
euch oft linke.de / doktor watson
erhaltet ihr 25 prozent rabatt auf ein
jahres abo blinkt ist premium und keine
sorge nach abschluss habt ihr immer noch
sieben tage zeit um linke ist kostenlos
zu testen hört sich gut an dann klickt
einfach auf den ersten link unten in der
video beschreibung und fangt an zu
lernen sein blick ist für die
unterstützung bei diesem video
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich fragt ihr euch jetzt hey
ich will auch keine steuern zahlen wie
geht das nun das kann ich euch ganz
einfach erklären wenn ihr nur meinen
2000 euro teuren kurs kauf links unten
in der video beschreibung hat spaß
beiseite ich verrate euch auch so der
trick ist ganz einfach elon musk
verdient offiziell gar nichts da er kein
gehalt bekommt er besitzt nur anteile
von tesla und anderen firmen okay aber
wie kommt er dann an geld ohne aktien zu
verkaufen und steuern zu zahlen ganz
einfach man leiht es sich und bietet
seine milliardenschweren aktien als
sicherheit und das ist ganz schön smart
denn kredite müssen in den usa nicht
versteuert werden wenn der kredit dann
mal fällig wird dann muss man aktien
verkaufen ja aber das geld daraus wird
praktischerweise mal halb so stark
besteuert wie ein einkommen zurück zahlt
man dann die zinsen die auch viel
geringer sind als einkommenssteuer
praktisch und genau so macht das
übrigens auch amazon gründer jeff bezos
gerüchten zufolge muss übrigens ihre
maskerade diese zinsen auf kredite bald
zurück bezahlen was eventuell der wahre
grund für seine abstimmung auf twitter
sein könnte aber zurück zum thema wenn
es mit den tricks nicht klappt oder
irgendwann der kredit abgezahlt werden
muss dann ist es wohl zeit für ihn und
macht sein geld ehrlich zu versteuern
mit dem verkauf von zehn prozent seiner
tesla aktien nimmt er ca 20,8 milliarden
dollar ein die steuer gehen davon
wahrscheinlich so um die fünf milliarden
deutlich weniger als wenn er das geld
als geheim bekommen hätte ok halten wir
also mal fest erstens es gibt
schlupflöcher überhaupt keine steuern
zahlen zu müssen und zweitens selbst
wenn es mal soweit ist sind das
geringere prozentsätze als für
normalverdiener ist das unfair eigene
meinung ja das vermögen haben
größtenteils die mitarbeitenden von
ihnen maß gearbeitet die davon aber bei
weitem nicht zu viel haben wie er und
sie müssen prozentual mehr von ihrem
verdienst abgeben ich finde die rechnung
vom anfang zeigt ganz gut dass niemand
im leben so hart arbeiten kann dass
diese person
280 milliarden dollar verdient hat
deswegen ist es ja nur fair regelmäßig
etwas zurückzugeben an die menschen die
teilweise für diesen erfolg
mitverantwortlich sind nicht alles aber
einen grösseren teil als die
allermeisten arbeiter und mit der
meinung bin ich nicht alleine in den usa
wird gerade eine super reichen steuer
diskutiert wichtig ihm geht es nicht um
ärzte anwälte oder geschäftsführer die
ziemlich gut verdienen sondern es geht
um menschen die so viel geld haben dass
man seit dem jahr null rechnen muss um
irgendwie zu verstehen wie unglaublich
viel das ist wo ist da die grenze aber
dann ist man superreich nun das ist
umstritten wirtschaftsanalysten ziehen
die grenze zum beispiel bei menschen mit
über 30 millionen oder über 100
millionen dollar vermögen eine super
reichen steuer heißt dass superreiche
wie elon musk nicht nur generell mal
regelmäßig steuern zahlen sollten
sondern auch mehr als aktuell gesetzlich
vorgesehen auch in deutschland stand in
manchen wahlprogrammen etwas von einer
neuen vermögenssteuer
das ist krass umstritten zumindest in
der politik aber was sagt eigentlich die
wissenschaft dazu ein kurzer disclaimer
anders als in der physik der biologie
oder der chemie ist die eine
faktenbasierte wissenschaftliche
wahrheit hier schwieriger zu finden
sozial und geisteswissenschaften
bedeuten debatten wir sind natürlich
bemüht hier verschiedene meinungen
zusammen zu bringen und zu
berücksichtigen trotzdem gehen wir
natürlich auch mit eigenen standpunkten
an so ein thema ran deswegen haben wir
für euch
super viele quellen gesammelt mit denen
ihr euch selber in das thema einarbeiten
könnt wenn ihr wollt die findet ihr wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
und wenn etwas wirklich nur meine eigene
meinung ist dann wird das natürlich wie
immer auch angezeigt also los geht's
2010 haben die reichsten ein prozent der
usa fast 1 5 bill des nationalen
einkommens ausgemacht übrigens fast das
gleiche verhältnis wie in den 1920 er
jahren kurz vor dem großen markt crash
und wenn man sich die daten aus den usa
aber auch deutschland anschaut dann geht
die schere zwischen arm und reich seit
30 jahren immer weiter auseinander ok
und warum eine sehr berühmte theorie
macht die vermögensverteilung
verantwortlich die top verdienenden sind
zu job verdienen also ganz wird gesagt
hat zu viel geld superreiche menschen
können logischerweise mehr sparen als
menschen die von der hand in den mund
leben und sparen lässt den reichtum der
oberen 1 prozent immer weiter wachsen
der gute alte zinseszins sowohl in den
usa als auch in deutschland wird eben
nur einkommen versteuert nicht das
vermögen und wenn man kein einkommen hat
sondern nur ein gewaltiges vermögen kann
das fahren sie steuerfrei wachsen und
wachsen und wachsen und genau so wächst
auch die ungleichheit der kern des
problems ist hier dass sich das ersparte
geld schneller vermehrt als das
wirtschaftswachstum des marktes und
solange diese tatsache gültig ist werden
reiche zwangsläufig reicher während der
rest abgehängt hört wenn man diese
formel immer weiter spielt dann haben
eine reiche und erden irgendwann alles
und der rest von uns da nichts mehr also
das hört sich nicht so spart sich an
aber darunter leiden natürlich nur
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter ohne
ersparnisse oder falsch gedacht selbst
aus streng kapitalistischer sicht wird
die aktuelle ungleichheit irgendwann
gift für die wirtschaft
und dafür gibt es vier gute gründe
erstens selbst wenn man ganz scharf auf
ewiges wirtschaftswachstum ist bringt so
eine ungerechte verteilung auf lange
sicht nichts gutes
wohlhabende menschen sparen mehr als sie
ausgeben und geld zu reichen menschen
fließt desto weniger wird ausgegeben
weil das geld nicht wirklich in den
umlauf kommt sondern auf dem konto
wächst zwei menschen wollen in der regel
ihren lebensstandard halten was passiert
aber wenn die löhne nicht steigen
vielleicht sogar sinken die inflation
aber alles teurer und teurer macht
höhere schulden um den konsum zu
finanzieren und um die schulden dann ab
zu bezahlen wird der konsum reduziert
drittens die motivation zu arbeiten
sinkt wenn der gewinn der arbeit nur an
die da oben geht während einer
arbeiterin oder ein arbeiter kaum die
miete bezahlen kann das kann sich auf
die produktivität auswirken hat dieses
paper hier herausgefunden und viertens
ungleichheit sorgt für politische
instabilität was im umkehrschluss
einfluss auf die wirtschaft nimmt
und jetzt kommt die große frage die
frage aller fragen was macht man dagegen
hier gibt es ganz grob drei ideen die am
meisten diskutiert werden möglichkeit
nummer eins wir machen so weiter wie
bisher oder wir gehen sogar noch einen
schritt weiter und geben wohlhabenden
menschen und unternehmen sogar extra
steuersenkungen ein argument dafür ist
wenn zum beispiel in maske mehr geld
behält kann er dieses investieren
wodurch neue arbeitsplätze entstehen und
vielleicht sogar die löhne steigen also
frei nach dem motto wenn es der firma
und reichen menschen gut geht dann fällt
für jeden etwas vom tisch und direkt mal
vorweg ob das alles so funktioniert das
wird stark von wissenschaftlern
bezweifelt zum beispiel amazon ist mega
erfolgreich und jeff bezos sehr sehr
reich doch in der realität sind seine
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter teilweise auf
lebensmittelmarken angewiesen während
ihr chef mit cowboyhut ins weltall
fliegen spät freudig und das ist so wie
es gerade läuft nicht weitergehen kann
davon sind inzwischen sogar konservative
wirtschaftswissenschaftler überzeugt
alles klar möglichkeit nummer eins beim
wir hoffen dass das bruttogehalt der
mitte und niedrigverdiener schneller
steigt als das der gut und bestverdiener
die schere würde sich dann langsam
wieder schließen aber auch das passiert
leider nicht das produktivitätswachstum
sinkt seit jahren bedeutet bei gleichem
einsatz von ressourcen und arbeitern
sinkt das produktionsergebnis und
produktivität ist der wichtigste faktor
damit die gehälter steigen und damit
kommen wir auch schon zum dritten und
letzten vorschlag der umverteilung und
die wahrscheinlich berühmteste methode
so einer umverteilung ist ihr ahnt es
schon eine steuer und zu meiner
überraschung ist die idee von so einer
steuer in der wissenschaft gar nicht so
kontrovers diskutiert zwei komplett
verschiedene seiten der wissenschaft
sind sich größtenteils einig dass die
aktuelle vermögensverteilung zu einem
immer größeren problem wird es gibt
sogar daten die darauf hinweisen dass
eine umverteilung diese ungleichheit zum
besseren verändern könnte historisch
korrelierten top steuern für die oberen
1 prozent mit dem niedrigsten einkommen
und besitz der 1 prozent und je weniger
bei den 1 prozent liegt desto mehr
findet sich im rest der gesellschaft
logisch die meinungen gehen dann wieder
auseinander wenn es dann darum geht wie
so eine neue steuer praktisch eingeführt
wird aber selbst die drei hort fans des
freien marktes schließen höhere steuern
nicht aus wenn das geld in zehn führende
dinge gesteckt wird die debatte ist also
nicht wie man vielleicht denken würde
reichensteuer ja oder nein die debatte
dreht sich vielmehr darum wie genau das
in der praxis aussieht und was mit dem
geld passieren soll also besteuert man
jetzt aktiengewinne stärker oder sollte
es eine vermögenssteuer werden wie jedes
jahr auf den gesamten besitz bezahlt
werden muss all das ist extrem schwierig
zu beantworten und dafür müsste man
wahrscheinlich auch erstmal einen weg
finden dass superreiche überhaupt
regelmäßig steuern zahlen dafür müsste
man wiederum gesetze ändern und das ist
alles nicht so einfach denn es gibt
hunderte player die alle ihre eigenen
interessen haben auch nicht sicher ist
was für negative effekte so eine
reichensteuer hetze
vor allem zwei dinge werden hier oft
genannt erstens was ist denn mit dem
wirtschaftswachstum aber wie eben schon
erklärt wird auch eine ungerechte
verteilung langfristig das wachstum
bremsen ein weiteres argument ist dass
es menschen die motivieren könnte wenn
sie so viel von ihrem einkommen an die
steuer abgeben müssen eigene meinung
hierzu ich glaube nicht dass elon musk
durch eine steuererhöhungen plötzlich
alles an den nagel hängt und nicht
weiter an seinen projekten arbeitet die
hohe bezahlung kommt ja nicht nur durch
harte arbeit sondern durch seine
wirtschaftliche macht position deswegen
rechnen wissenschaftler auch nicht damit
dass das wachstum unter einer steuer
leidet quelle ein weiteres typisches
argument das gegen höhere steuern
wirklich immer wieder kommt lautet wenn
wir milliardäre mehr besteuern dann
ziehen sie eben woanders hin wo die
steuern niedriger ist und da würden
wahrscheinlich sogar befürworter der
reichensteuer zustimmen geld ist
heutzutage so mobil dass es für menschen
mit genug ressourcen wirklich kein
problem ist schlupflöcher zu finden oder
ganz einfach den staat oder sogar den
kontinent zu wechseln was macht man dann
gegen nun gerade wurde eine globale
mindeststeuer beschlossen die richtet
sich aber leider nur an unternehmen und
ist mit 15 jetzt auch nicht so mega hoch
und so wirklich global ist sie auch noch
nicht aber zumindest kann man sagen dass
das ein schritt in die richtige richtung
ist denn sollte man es irgendwie
schaffen und sich auf eine super
reichensteuer zu einigen dann bringt es
eben nicht viel das nur in einem land zu
machen es bräuchte internationale
zusammenarbeit von behörden um
sicherzustellen dass man seine
milliarden nicht mal eben steuerfrei auf
den cayman islands parken kann
[Musik]
okay das waren jetzt ganz schön viele
zahlen und wir haben echt super viel
recherchiert um das alles irgendwie
zusammen zu bringen trotzdem wenn ihr
euch dafür interessiert dann geht gerne
selber mal in die primärquellen unten in
der video beschreibung rein schaut es
euch selber an wie schon erwähnt ist das
ganze thema eine laufende debatte aber
um das ganze zusammen zu fassen ich muss
sagen was wir gelesen haben hat uns
überrascht da schon ziemlich eindeutig
in eine richtung geht wenn die
vermögensverteilung sich weiter so
entwickelt dann bekommen wir noch mehr
probleme als wir ohnehin schon haben und
um das zu lösen finde ich persönlich die
argumente für eine super reichensteuer
ziemlich überzeugend natürlich muss man
auch immer sehen dass das in den usa
nochmal um einiges schlimmer ist aber
auch hier in deutschland finde ich das
keine schlechte idee die frage bleibt
nur eben wie machen wir das wie sorgen
wir dafür dass man nicht einfach das
land wechselt wenn man ein superreicher
ist und die steuer kommt und am
wichtigsten wie sorgt man dafür dass das
geld verteilt wird und mitte und
geringverdienern zugute kommt hier gehen
die meinungen von forscherinnen und
forschern übrigens wieder sehr weit
auseinander aber das ist ein thema für
ein anderes video denn dieses video hier
ist schon mehr als lang genug geworden
wenn ihr mehr solcher videos hier sehen
wollt solche auch finanzthemen die ist
ja nicht so typisch für doktor watson
dann schreib mir das gerne mal in die
kommentare wir sind hier sehr gespannt
auf euer feedback ansonsten wenn ihr
weitere doktor watson videos sehen wollt
dann abonniert den kanal um nichts zu
verpassen wenn wir was neues hoch laden
und ansonsten wie immer bleibt neugierig
patrick
[Musik]